who are you listening to man what are
the albums you got in rotation bruh i
mean i'm only right now listening to
black iverson and future album is the
future album good
the first seven songs man i can't
i can't stop listening to it so i've
heard that on twitter and then i see
other people on twitter just like just
saying it's not i mean i don't know you
talking i don't know i'm not even you're
a fan on twitter right now so i'm not i
don't know what the [ __ ] the internet is
saying future uh they just said on the
cover of gq uh-huh did you see his cover
of gq
they said he's the greatest rapper alive
on the cover of gq right now that's the
headline right now
in the in terms
i think culturally
future more important than drake right
now
or no i'm sorry it wasn't even the
greatest the word was the best
rapper alive is he the best
not the greatest
because i just had this debate with
spotify
it's the best rapper alive do you think
future's the best rapper alive currently
yeah
keyword best
keyword rapper
i mean if we saying keyword rapper right
now investor uh i don't know
i don't know if i would say that i think
he up there though who's the best rapper
alive to you
at this very moment at this very moment
i think steel kendrick
i respect that answer
yeah anything to drop so i'm excited to
see what he do but i'll really be trying
to separate what is a rapper like the
job of a rapper
versus lyricist that i respect i think
in terms of lyricism kendrick is really
untouchable and he's still a person that
the culture is what every side waits for
and that's real pivotal because i'm but
and also when i think best
i think um about who can have the most
pivotal moments in that in the culture
like
really influential
and currently
drake's influence is long-lasting and he
changed like the sound of how people
even record right and [ __ ] like that but
currently mo [ __ ] is copying future
everybody that is popular all the big
[ __ ] influential wise i think future's
got a way bigger influence for me yeah i
think that's why you could say
a [ __ ] had an argument that he
the best because everybody that's
popping either has to work with him
wants to work with him or they sound
like him
everybody he just futures just don't
i don't think he'd do the same monetary
numbers as like the other [ __ ] who we
would say but culturally he got to be
one of the best if not the best i i damn
near i'm starting to agree
you talked yourself into it yup that's
fair